et nous retrouvons tout de suite
Gulliver crack avec Danilo moquerie
journaliste d'investigation
oui bonjour alors vous imaginez bien le
24 février 2022 l'Ukraine et sous le
choc le pays étant désarroi mais il y a
aussi un très grand sentiment d'unité
nationale alors que on Ukraine il existe
une communauté très dynamique de
journalistes dont le rôle est vraiment
de critiquer le pouvoir et de faire la
lumière sur des histoires de corruption
daniloquer mon invité on fait partie
Danilo au début de cette invasion à
grande échelle vous avez un peu changé
d'approche n'est-ce pas oui c'est ça
parce qu'on se disait bien que dans les
premiers mois qui suivaient l'invasion
les gens ont le public s'intéressaient
pas vraiment à l'anti corruption et aux
investigations de la corruption alors on
a dû de changer d'approche et de
commencer
à parler des crimes de guerre parler de
la guerre et à faire des domestiquer
tout ça tout ce qui concerne à la guerre
pendant les deux trois premiers mois de
la grande guerre on faisait en fait et
ça vous avez fait pour un public
ukrainien ou étranger je sais que vous
avez fait aussi des reportages en
anglais on a commencé pour
pour le public ukrainien mais au bout
d'un moment on s'est dit que bon il
fallait quand même peut-être parler
aussi au public international c'est pour
ça qu'on a commencé à faire quelques pas
beaucoup mais quand même quelques sujets
par mois en anglais aussi et en début de
cette année 2023 les choses j'ai
l'impression ont de nouveaux changés un
peu puisqu'il y a eu de nombreuses
histoires de corruption qui ont vu le
jour quel a été votre réaction notamment
à cette histoire où il y avait un
contrat de 300 millions d'euros pour
l'alimentation de l'armée visiblement
avec des prix extraordinairement gonflés
en tant que citoyen je suis bien sûr en
dîner en tant que journaliste je me dis
ah bon il y a quand même il y a quand
même des choses qui n'ont pas changé
mais il faut se dire aussi que si on
si on apprend des choses sur la
corruption en Ukraine surtout l'histoire
que que vous venez de de mentionner
c'est parce que l'Ukraine a la presse
libre qui en parle et puis parce que
l'Ukraine a des agences anti corruption
qui font leur travail et communiquent
alors je me dis que bon d'un côté la
corruption c'est mauvais et ça on dit
vraiment surtout en temps de guerre et
avec toutes les sacrifices
qu'on vit aujourd'hui mais je me dis
aussi que bon ça signifie quand même si
on en parle qu'on a les journalistes
libres qui peuvent le faire et qui on a
des agences d'anticruption qui qui
travaillent quoi bien sûr la propagande
russe se sert de ces histoires de
corruption parce que cela nuit en
quelque sorte à l'image de l'Ukraine
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il faut tout
de même continuer à travailler malgré la
possibilité que ce soit par la
propagande russe oui bien sûr je le
pense qu'il faut en parler c'est une
c'est toute discussion qu'on a en
Ukraine parmi les journalistes s'il faut
parler aujourd'hui de la corruption en
Ukraine parce que ça ni à l'image de
l'Ukraine parce que ça a peut-être
rend les Occidentaux moins convaincus
qu'il faut aider l'Ukraine mais on se
dit que si on veut changer la situation
si on veut combattre la corruption si on
veut faire de l'Ukraine en pays plus
fort bah il faut en parler il faut
investiguer il fait publier et
voilà parce qu'il y a pas il y a pas
d'autres moyens quoi et est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que depuis 2014 et ces
manifestations sûrement Eden qui était
en grande partie des manifestations
contre la corruption il y a eu des
progrès au Ukraine il y a eu des
réformes qui ont qui ont mené à quelque
chose oui ça c'est c'est même pas
question de ça c'est vrai
ça a beaucoup changé vous pouvez
consulter par exemple
là on dise de perception de la
corruption de l'organisation
transparente et internationale qui dit
que depuis 2013 l'Ukraine a gagné 8
points et c'est un des progrès les plus
significatifs dans la dizaine des années
qui ont qui sont écoulés alors il y a eu
vraiment beaucoup de progrès mais on
veut toujours plus on veut toujours
mieux quoi Danilo merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité merci et dans le cadre
de nos éditions spéciales pour marquer
cet anniversaire j'avais aussi envie de
revenir sur ces événements qui ont
certainement marqué un très grand
tournant dans les relations entre
l'Ukraine et la Russie les
manifestations sur la place maidane en
2013 2014 qui ont conduit au départ du
président Victoria nokovic qui avait
refusé de signer un accord d'association
avec l'Union européenne citant la
pression de la Russie c'est alors en
fait un autre journaliste
d'investigation il était alors
journaliste d'investigation Mustapha
naïem qui a appelé à manifester sur la
place maidane à Kiev il y a deux jours
je suis allé le retrouver sur cette même
place
nous sommes sur la place Maiden avec
Mustapha Naïm c'est lui qui a appelé un
manifesté ici en novembre 2013 contre le
président victoriakovic Mustapha ce
processus s'est manifestation qui ont
conduit au départ de Victoria nokovic
sont aujourd'hui qualifiés par la Russie
de coup d'état orchestré par les
Américains et exécutés par l'extrême
droite ukrainienne c'était quoi en
réalité
je pense que ceux qui disent ça ne
connaissent pas l'histoire de l'Ukraine
ils ne comprennent pas notre lutte pour
la liberté
pendant des siècles l'Ukraine a été au
cœur de différents empires qui ont
occupé son territoire alors c'est une
lutte qui a commencé il y a de très
longues années nous n'avions pas compris
qu'il y aurait la guerre mais
aujourd'hui avec le recul nous
comprenons que ce mouvement faisait
partie de notre lutte pour les libertés
et que nous n'avions pas d'autre choix
et depuis vous êtes entre en politique
vous êtes aujourd'hui à la tête de
l'Agence nationale pour la restauration
de l'infrastructure les dégâts sont
estimés à plus de 130 milliards de
dollars déjà par où commencer a fait que
ce n'est pas encore vraiment le moment
de parler de reconstruction en fait on
est dans la phase de survie nous
comprenons que l'infrastructure critique
le système d'énergie les zones
résidentielles sont notre priorité pour
cette année après la victoire je pense
qu'on va commencer la vraie
reconstruction avec un plan stratégique
pour le pays et nous ne voulons pas
refaire l'Union soviétique nous voulons
construire quelque chose de meilleur
pour cela nous avons besoin d'expertise
nous avons besoin d'argent de ressources
humaines du soutien de nos partenaires
justement vous avez évoqué ces
partenaires comment assurer les
partenaires de l'Ukraine qui vont
financer en partie la reconstruction que
les fonds ne seront pas détournés par
des officiels corrompus nous comprenons
ces inquiétudes ici en Ukraine nous
comprenons que notre plus grand atout
c'est la confiance
pour cela nous changeons nos procédures
et nous voulons être aussi fiables et
aussi transparent que possible pour tous
les donateurs et institutions
financières internationales qui
collaborent avec nous et je pense que le
monde a changé son approche envers
l'Ukraine dans le sens politique et dans
le sens militaire personne ne
s'attendait à ce que l'Ukraine
résisterait pendant tout ce temps il
faut désormais changer son approche
croire qu'on est capable de faire les
choses de manière transparente et
ouverte nous voulons le prouver et nous
invitons tous nos partenaires à venir et
voir nos progrès Mustapha merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité
et merci beaucoup à Gulliver Cragg